let's get into the things that are
happening around the national football
league and i'll tell you what one of the
one of the big questions that texans
will do with sean watson we've talked
about whether or not russell wilson
wants out of seattle
there's another quarterback out there
and i don't know that franchise
quarterback is the right term he was an
mvp finalist if not the presumptive mvp
winner in 2017 before he tore his acl
in december of that year against the
rams nick foles comes in obviously and
leads the eagles to a super bowl win but
carson wentz with that 33.5 million
dollar contract
the eagles ready to move on whence ready
to move on
there seemed to be a week and a half ago
peter a strong
idea that they were going to get a deal
done and now it's just crickets
and no one can figure out where this is
and i think the bottom line is the
eagles just aren't getting what they
think they should
and so they're waiting and i have no
idea how long they're going to be
waiting
but they're content to wait at least for
now unless and until someone gives them
what
they're looking for it really is crazy
that that
that they can't get this done wence is
motivated
and at least the cults would assume to
be motivated i think the big problem is
it's just the cults that there really
isn't another serious suitor
so it's just a waiting game between the
colts and the eagles at this point
man i'd be really surprised if the bears
were not serious about him
very surprised you know you've got john
defilippo
uh in you know the passing game
coordinator now he's been promoted
in in the ears of the general manager
ryan
pace and the coach matt nagy uh
i'd just be very surprised if he wasn't
pushing
you know they had a great relationship
in 2017
in the year that the uh the eagles
won the super bowl and you know the two
guys who were there who were
really significant uh in carson wentz's
rise that year obviously
frank wright the offensive coordinator
now in indianapolis
john de filippo uh you know in chicago
and he had been the quarterback coach so
i
i
still believe it's going to come down to
those two teams mike
but if you're howie roseman you're
sitting here right now
and you've got 30 days until
uh you get to the start of the next
league here you've got to trade carson
wentz
by day three of the league year because
then if you haven't traded him by then
he would be due
a 10 million dollar roster bonus so
you look at this situation you ask
yourself well
you know what's holding everybody up and
naturally what's holding everybody up is
the value
because carson wentz has not been great
since 2017.
now he's been good often in 18 and 19
but he just came off a year
when he played at a trubisky level and
so you
can't just automatically sit there and
say i'm gonna give you a one and a four
for this guy
it's it's more complicated than that but
if you're howie roseman i look at it and
you say what's the rush
let's just let's just hang out and wait
you don't get anything you don't get
extra credit
if you make the trade a month before you
have to
and coincidentally the one and the four
that you mentioned was the package that
the eagles got in 2016
for sam browder then with the vikings
suffered the
catastrophic knee injury non-contact
it's always non-contact for a
quarterback
at practice unless unless contact
happens accidentally but it was clearly
non-contact
season over vikings cough up the one and
the four for bradford at a time when
bradford was
poised to be the week one starter with
carson wentz then a rookie on the bench
but the eagles waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited to the
point where we didn't even know they
were still waiting
and that offer falls into their laps now
i don't think you can bank on a
quarterback suffering a catastrophic
knee injury and all of a sudden
there's a belated market for carson
wentz and i think the key is and this is
where you have to get
jeffrey lurie fully on board with the
approach
because as you mentioned march 19 10
million dollar roster bonus it's already
guaranteed
whoever has that contract is paying it
but
the the check gets cut on the 19th
that's 10 million out of your pocket and
and if you're the eagles because i peter
i
feel like because of what the lions got
for matthew stafford
i feel like the eagles feel compelled to
come away from this with a better deal
i it occurred to me yesterday could they
just pay the 10 million
and then fold that money into
the trade request and you get more for
carson wentz at that point
because you've already paid 10 million
of the dollars that he's due to make
so then when it's done you can say to
anybody who may say you didn't get
enough well look at what we got well one
of the reasons you got what you got
is because you paid into 10 million and
his new team didn't have to
i think it's a good point mike and i
think it's a it's logical
but i'll tell you if you're the
acquiring team
and you make a trade on you know april
30th
or april 25th for carson wentz
i mean why should you be the ones
to pay for a bad
contract you're already paying a lot
more than you want to
that 10 million dollars in my opinion
should be the eagles penalty
for 18 months ago paying carson wentz
too soon
get for him which is going to be less
than what they would have gotten if they
had traded him after the 2018 season and
kept nick foles instead
something that some suggested they
should seriously consider and i never
got the impression
that they seriously considered it see
the problem is they gave up so much to
get him
in 2016. they weren't going to keep
falls over him after the 2018 season
because they believed he was their guy
and then they paid him
to get themselves even deeper into this
and and
that it amazes me that they are willing
to extricate and not keep him
part of it may be he just wants out and
they know it's impractical
to to keep a franchise quarterback in
place who doesn't want to be with the
franchise anymore
but this is not the time to be trading
him i know that the eagles believe
that this is similar to ben
roethlisberger's third season 2006 which
was
a regression he recovered from it
quickly peyton manning's fourth season
of 2001 the jim mora
playoffs year maura got fired peyton
manning
significantly regressed that year he
recovered but
you're going to give up significant
draft pick compensation on the hope
on the chance on the roll of the dice
status quo for carson wentz that's the
problem peter they always told me buy
low and sell high
the eagles are trying to sell low
i i you know i can't buy any of the
arguments
that they would make because this past
year you know mike there were 36
qualifiers
in the nfl 36 quarterbacks qualified
you know playing a minimal amount
uh throwing a minimal amount of passes
36
qualified for the passer rating
in the national football league and
carson wentz was 35th
and he was one-tenth of a point ahead of
sam darnold
so i i'm not i'm not buying the
well you know roethlisberger was lousy
in his third year too
and and all this i'm not i'm not buying
it
even though roethlisberger in his third
year had a negative
uh uh touchdown to interception ratio
he didn't hit rock bottom the way carson
wentz just did
and in addition to that there
are also all the stories about how he
became very difficult to coach
how you couldn't really tell him
anything and how he reacted
very adversely and and you know look
i think i said this maybe a month ago on
our show mike but
buckybrooks of nfl.com had the absolute
perfect take
when adam schefter reported that carson
wentz is angry oh you don't want to make
carson wentz angry
buggy brooks said you know what getting
appointed a starting quarterback in the
nfl
is not a lifetime appointment
and carson wentz thought it was and he's
got he was in for a rude surprise
so why then would the bears
even think about this i understand john
d filippo has the history and
i don't know what hefty has in the
organization yeah but
but peter think about this from both
sides
if you're the bears and you just went
through the mitchell trubisky experience
and they're never going to let you
forget locally that you could have
taken patrick mahomes or deshaun watson
instead you trade up to get trubisky
and the bears fans have been waiting for
a franchise quarterback
since sid luckman and you bring a guy to
like first of all how are bears fans
going to react my guess is they're going
to be dubious at best about the
possibility of carson wentz taking over
and it's only going to go downhill from
there if he stinks right out of the
gates
and then if you're wentz if you're wence
and you just got out of philly alive
do you really want to step into chicago
at a time when it's not damn well if you
have any well
well it is up to you if you make it
known you don't want to play for the
bears if i'm the bears
and i know this guy doesn't want to play
for me i don't want him
even without a no trade clause i don't
want a franchise quarterback who already
has a history of being a little entitled
and there were there were stories about
carson wentz
and his failure to to you know establish
the right connection with his teen old
and he was
arrogant that was pre the 2019 season
those reports came out from unnamed
sources and when he addressed it he
legitimized it and he said he's trying
to get better
so i just think there's too many
questions with carson wentz
and i think chicago is a disaster
waiting to happen
and trust me we root for disasters in
this business it's good to have
dysfunction dysfunction sells
but i don't think it's good for anybody
for wants to go to chicago i think that
at the end of the day
the cults are the only team that makes
sense and that's why they're having a
hard time reaching a consensus because
chris balor the gm of the team can sit
back with his arms folded
and just wait for harry to call and say
all right fine i'll take your offer
and it was ron jaworski last week the
eagles great
who got a super bowl ring from the team
when they finally won the super bowl
that's how much affection they have for
him
he goes on a tv or somewhere
he said that all the colts have offered
his two second round draft picks
for carson wentz and that's why the deal
isn't done and and i think
i think two second-round picks
considering the contract you're taking
on
i think two second round picks is a damn
good deal and the eagles if it's on the
table should jump on it
mike you know what's what is one of the
most laughable
concepts imaginable in football today
and there are many of them
and that is that the 35th
rated quarterback in the nfl
in 2020 says he wants to be traded
and when uh he is traded or or they're
closing in on a trade
with the chicago bears if that ever
happens if the 35th rated quarterback
in the nfl says whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
i'm not going to chicago i mean
is that the ultimate the
ultimate overplaying of your hand the
ultimate
overplaying of who in the world do you
think you
are you know if you request a trade
and you come off a year where you're
awful
you just i you know i i don't this is
going to sound dramatic i mean
just shut up and go be good i don't care
if you get traded to saskatchewan
it's ridiculous to even think that he
would do that
but it's consistent with the mindset
that's led us to where we are now the
fact that he was threatened by jalen
hurts
when jay glazer of fox reported during
the season it messed him up
having hurts there when they use a
second round pick on jalen hurts that
that
that sapped his confidence and then what
did we hear
throughout the back end of the season he
wants out he wants out relationships
fractured with doug peterson
okay peterson's gone he still wants out
so if the guy's willing
to with the team that has paid him all
that money
with the team that's tried to make him
into a franchise quarterback
if he's willing to show attitude with
them and he's been there for five years
now
why would he not hesitate to show
or why would he hesitate to show
attitude with a team that he's never
played for
i don't want to play for the bears i i
don't
given what we know and given where we
are right now with carson wentz i don't
think it's a stretch at all for him to
make it known
through his agent through whoever to the
bears
that you're probably going to regret
this if you do it because he doesn't
want to play for you and if and if they
told me that
right on one hand oh and this is this is
the this is the
confluence of old school football george
young too bad
you tell him tough crap right he doesn't
determine where he plays or who he plays
for he signed a contract and they traded
and he
they traded here he's got to live with
it new school
we better be careful because we don't
want a starting quarterback who doesn't
want to be here
it's it's another example of this
ongoing
effort by quarterbacks to to flex their
muscles peter
maybe it still it still would be the
goal of the year
uh for that to happen mike let me ask
you a question
because this intrigues me when i hear
what ron jaworski said what would you
rather have
would you rather have the colts next two
second round picks which i believe would
be about
53rd and then whatever it is in
2022 so let's just say about the 50th
pick in the next two drafts
or would you like to have the 21st pet
pick
this year what would you take if i
offered that to you
well given the lack of a scouting
combine
given that this year is going to be even
more of a crap shoot than last year was
when it comes to drafting talent
i probably would rather have two lottery
tickets instead of one
and and because i know the second one
i'm gonna have a better chance to have
an idea what's under the metallic paint
than i am under this one uh so i'd
rather have two i'd
i'd always rather have more than less
but obviously the earlier you pick the
better but i just
it's going to be a challenge this year
with no scouting combine it's going to
be a challenge this year teams are going
to the reason they have to make their
their assessments based on what's on
film
i'll tell you this the reason any day of
the week
i would rather have tutus right now
at this point in time you just mention
it mike
there is really no sure thing
anymore you know because you're gonna do
a lot of scouting
you're gonna have fewer games to scout
on this year than you did a year ago and
to me
it's one of the reasons why i believe
that john schneider
didn't have that much of a fear about
trading his next two ones
for jamal adams because he figured that
they were both going to be somewhere 25
28 in the next two years and
you know really why wouldn't you take a
sure thing but i'll tell you this
while when i asked that question i
wanted to look it up
okay and so i'm just going to tell you
right now the picks
excuse me right around 50 to 55 okay and
i'm going to go down to 49
pittsburgh chase claypool 49
los angeles rams cam acres 52
philadelphia number 53 jalen hurts
baltimore number 55 jk dobbins
okay so you look at all that and you
look at a lot of the guys that got
picked right in that area and then
i could go up and and look higher around
20
and just say i'd rather have two lottery
tickets
exactly as you would say so if i were
the eagles
i might say uh you throw in a five
two twos and a five and we'll make that
deal
i might rather have that deal than if
chicago traded me the 20th pick in the
draft
another thing i'd like to have too and i
wish this got used more often i think
teams don't want to
tie up a range of draft picks because
let's say for example
someone would offer the eagles 2022
compensation
based on carson wentz's performance or
the number of games he plays in or the
team's performance whatever formula you
come up with
you have a second pick that is driven by
what you get from carson wentz in 2021
but the problem is
that team would then have maybe two all
the way down to five
you couldn't trade it you couldn't move
it because you have to hold on to it
because you don't know what you're
ultimately going to be giving the eagles
after carson wentz's first year with the
team that gives everyone some protection
i just think that's
fair especially with a player who has
question marks and carson wentz has
plenty of question marks so if he comes
in he's a superstar
i'll give you a first round pick in 2022
if he's the league mvp or if we win the
super bowl
take my first round pick and if he if he
plays half of the games
you get my fifth round pick that's fair
but
teams won't do it because they don't
want to tie their hands
for you know their entire draft if they
have a broad range if they have a
formula
that could have anywhere from pick one
all the way down to pick five six or
seven
that goes to a team but that that's the
fair way to do it
compensation based on the performance of
the player especially for a guy like
this
when the eagles are trying to sell the
idea that 2020 was some sort of an
aberration peter
i you know i think that's smart mike but
the one thing that i would say
is that you're already d if you traded
let's say
a two in this year's draft and then
a conditional something in 2022 remember
you're already devaluing uh the pick
you've got to take some risk when you
make a trade like this
because if you do get the carson wentz
of 2017
then think of how cheap you're getting
them even for a two
and a middle to low one so
anyway i look i think the indianapolis
colts
obviously are interested in carson wentz
frank wright loves them
so but i i guess the overarching thing i
would say is
there's no hurry there's a month they
got a month to go
if we're still talking about this it's
february 15th
if we're still talking about this on
march 15th
that's when you know you should be
concerned
the problem is frankly there was a sense
that was created a week and a half ago
that it was imminent and that may have
the colts to overdo it now this idea
that the bears were getting ready to
send a first round pick and nick foles
and tariq cohen to the eagles
that may have been an effort to try to
get the colts to jump because i think
what the eagles would like to do
is just be done with this we got other
things to worry about we just want to
get this done
but patience may be the thing that gets
them to where they ultimately want
to be and where that's going to be is
jalen hurts most likely the starter
they're firm believers in having a
second
quarterback and i don't rule out a
separate transaction with the bears that
would bring nick foles back to town as
the back up to jalen hurts
that would make it his third stint with
the team but just another one of the
many stops on the quarterback carousel
that's already spinning and will
continue to do so for weeks if not
months
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports